hey everyone it's your buddy Josh here
to break down one of my favorite alltime
stories this happened with a friend of
mine and I at the San Antonio Zoo truly
one of the most remarkable 20 minutes of
My Life by the way I'm just going to get
ahead of it and apologize for how tight
those pants are my buddy and I were
drunk at the
zoo and we were there near closing time
there was like around six or seven we
were hammered we're walking around we're
making fun of animals and
[__] and uh and we get to the Rhino P by
the way this is one of those stories
that I i' I've for whatever
reason very rarely told or tell on
stage and my buddy goes look at that
crazy how big that thing is right and he
goes it's weird that they're scared of
scared of people right and they go
said no no no you this this animal has a
sword on its
face this is one of those punchlines
that I had told it a couple
times and realized that that was a good
spot timing
wise um and it needed a little bit of a
laugh when you're telling a story like
this I would say any story every joke
doesn't have to be a 10 out of 10 to
keep you want to keep the story going
and a story can't ride at 10 the whole
time it it gets people exhausted a good
story has Peaks and valleys in my mind
and but sometimes even in the valley of
when you're just talking or in the
middle of the story it just needs a
haaha I'll tell you something else at
the end of a long
silence if you time it right you're
going to get the biggest laugh it breaks
the tension but in this little spot I
remember telling this a couple times on
stage and thinking to myself hey the
next time you tell this this is a good
spot for a joke and I this just came to
me one night on stage about the sword on
its face is it the best joke in the
world no but this spot in the story it
didn't need to be it just needs to be a
little entertaining they don't make you
with a sword on your face if you're
scared of people you know what I mean no
no they're like cows they run away from
people
nothing he says to me
$20 so that I don't jump in the pen with
a r by the way I want you guys to know
so far 100% trip this a 100% true him
jumping in that pen with the Rhino 100%
true that he only wanted $20 100% true
he's a heart surgeon now by the way I'm
in college in the90s $20 is 10 beers
that's a lot you know what I'm saying
and so I was like 20 bucks you don't
jump in the B he goes 20 bucks and he
goes 20 more bucks if I touch it on the
ass I said
dude now the pen this R's name was Lord
and it was a long rectangular pen these
are some choices that I make guys that
other people don't and this is
stylistically just for me I like you to
have a mental image of where you are in
the world I like you to be at the zoo
with me I could have just said he jumped
in the pen right but I like you to be
invested and I feel like the more
information you have the more I can
paint the picture for you I I remember
early on as a comic telling stories
where I had older guys be like get to it
you get rid of this you don't need it
and I did and I I remember being on
stage thinking this doesn't feel right
they're not investing Ed they're not
there with me and I think details put
you there with me which is why my
stories
man are are some of them are 15 20
minutes right because I'm I'm adding
things into these stories that I think
are important for you to enjoy them it
was at the end of the pen behind a a
wooden fence and it was a fence and it
had an opening big enough for the Riner
to get out right so
so he now this dude he was wearing jeans
tighter than M uh he jumps in wearing
these wrangles he had cowboy boots on
he's like this little 546 dude from West
Texas his name is Jack by the way he is
now a heart
surgeon see now this is one of the
reasons that I don't like to watch
myself and I like to listen and this is
just me being
hypercritical my motion on stage is a
little too erratic
right here I don't like I stepped back
sideways I steep back it's not how I
would tell a story to somebody in my
living room and so I don't mind the slow
movements or the back and forth but that
felt erratic to me and so in that moment
what that tells me is I'm not as
comfortable and interesting I wonder
what that is that spot
why now the Rhino pen is a the walls are
cement walls it's not like there's steps
up and down so he grabs on the side and
he just lets go and he drops in I bet
you the Wall's probably 9 and 1 half 10
ft maybe a little less maybe 8 and so he
starts to walk up to the run and it's
the end of the long pen probably
probably the end of this club probably
and he's walking up to me doing and he's
turning to me so he'll turn around he's
doing something like
this and the Rhino's not
moving and for a second I was
like do I not know what rhinos
do right like why isn't this rhino
sticking his horn up this dude's
[__] this is what we're paying the
money for you know what I
mean I wish I didn't say you know what I
mean as much as I do the I've heard it a
couple times and it feels like I'm
asking for validation at first when I
first started doing it I'm G to have to
think about that because when I first
started doing it I was looking for
remember I told you guys I was I really
want to address everybody as friends and
I it made it way more informal I think a
couple of them is okay but I think the
more I say you know what I mean the more
it feels like I'm asking you for
permission and I just want to tell the
story I I it's interesting again never
watched this and I don't I don't think
I've ever listened to this story either
because I just it's not a story that I
generally tell on
stage it's this is such a good example
of my
standup guys there are so many jokes
there's probably almost two specials
worth of jokes that I have never put in
specials that I just put out for you
guys this being a good example there's a
couple of that the jump the me jumping
off the Space Needle never been in a
special it's 17 minutes and so this is a
good example of that that and I've never
that's why I've never seen it or really
listened to
it he's getting closer and closer with
not a care in the world I'm like what is
happening he probably got within it
feels like 15
ft and the Rhino just looked at him and
let up this
noise I never heard a noise like that
before in my life d
whenit I was like oh that's what a real
animal sounds like
just thank
you and my buddy turned to me the
there's no reason to break up the flow
of your joke
to get into the dude making a Chewbacca
noise it it was fine that people laughed
at it but you don't have to really
respond to everything if you do you're
taking the bait and you're inviting
other people to make Chewbacca noises or
other noises or anything like that right
and this was just one of those times
where I couldn't not acknowledge it
because everybody heard and a bunch of
people laughed but I didn't want to get
into it and break up the flow of the
joke and I was like there's the fear I'm
looking
for this dude straight up realized oh I
made a big
mistake and the Rhino turns and it it's
not that Nimble right but when it gets
out the hole yo I'll tell you something
right now rhinos are faster than I
thought they
were this thing and it's got those
little tiny legs I'm like how is it
moving so
F you know and so it's but
and my budd's
just and I was like oh this is going to
be
close this is one of those stories that
I realized early on I don't need to make
anything up this dude jumped in the pen
with a rhino you know what I mean and I
reached my hand down over the
side and I go come on man I go grab my
hand and the rhinos
and he's guys by the way I wish I had a
picture of what his face look
like but you've never seen fear until
you've seen someone chased by a
rhino that is a fear that you don't
expect to ever unlock you know what I'm
saying that's deep
dark it's a good example here again as
I've started telling stories I want to
relate to the people that are listening
and watching and so in the story when I
can dip back and talk about something
like that that kind of fear that we've
all either experienced or seen somebody
experience I I like the relatable laughs
I like I want them to be funny but I
also
want you and the people listening to be
like oh I I know that guy I am that guy
was that guy that that that's my
favorite type of humor so that is really
what I try to put out
there he
runs he puts one jumps One Foot In The
Wall grabs my hand all of my weight I
just pull lift him up out of that pen
want I tell you how close it is dude I
lifted him up the Rhino was so close to
him the Rhino ran into the
wall rhinos don't stop on a you know
what I
mean they don't really have breaks you
know what I mean this dude do you know
what I
mean it drives me crazy just watching
this that double you know what I mean is
like fingernails on a chalkboard to me
you know what I
mean into the
wall my budd's laying there out of
breath just not saying anything I'm
laying there laughing my ass off I'm
like God I almost saw you die right now
you're like you're righto almost split
you in two
bro and we're walking out of the zoo
quiet he hasn't said a word and then he
looks at me and he goes hippo not Rhino
hippo and I go no to no hippo
NE again hippo not Rhino not written
said like it really it was such a
natural beginning middle end of a story
but I'm going to tell you why I didn't
tell it for a long time it's already a
Fantastical story right there was a
while
there where I I didn't feel like I was a
good enough Storyteller to tell it I was
not
confident I should have made notes of it
in here but when I say that's the fear I
was looking for there it's not like a
punchline but it's it's an in the moment
because I've described to you and put
you in the
world that you're there with me that
you're you and you're understanding my
point of view that's the
laugh that type of Storytelling where
it's not I'm not I can't think of a lot
of like punch lines
hippo not Rhino punchline but it was
more feeling being there oh my God I
can't believe that's
happening and laughing at at at human
emotion and real things that are
happening right that to me is a
different type of Storytelling when
you're you have to bring people into the
world to get to laugh and for a long
that happened in college for a long time
I would whenever I Would Tell It On
Stage I would get get maybe a chuckle or
two and I would get a round of applause
at the end of the story I don't want a
round of applause I'll take it if it
comes after the laughs but I this is not
a rally it's not a speech I want the
laughter and so for a while I didn't I
didn't feel like I was a good enough
Storyteller to do that story Justice um
and I I I honestly that especially
somebody just asked me the question and
just kind of not a story that I tell all
the time that felt exactly how besides
then you know what I means how I want to
tell stories very conversational very
natural um and I wish I hadn't posted
this so I could do it on my next special
all right everybody I hope you had a
good time man I love breaking down these
stories I love the comedy nerd aspect I
would love to maybe do one where I
answer some of your questions about the
joke before I do the video I'll have to
figure out how to make that happen thank
you for tuning in to the channel thank
you for watching the videos super
grateful for all of you comedian Josh
wolf.com for tour dates talk to you soon